from my talk of the table we've got a
very special guest this morning first
we've got to go to the control room
because
control room can we bring in some music
while we're making this introduction
why because he loves his song we're
talking a hall of fame coach and cbs
sports
analyst that's bill cower before these
fancy titles that's for you bill
he was just billy from crafton pa now
he's an author his new book heart and
steel
is published by simon schuster a
division of viacom cbs
andy takes us along in his journey as a
player for cleveland
in philadelphia but most of them know
most of us know him for his success
as the head coach of the pittsburgh
steelers 15 seasons listen to this
record
he led the team to eight division titles
in their 2006 super bowl win bill
cower joins us first on cbs this morning
bill carrera what's the name of that
song
that's uh the way of the world now gail
yeah
yep on page 17 you said that sort of
described my life in many ways but
this is what i want to say to you bill
cower i stay i read your book
i had no idea about your history i had
no idea you were such a big deal and
that you were such a
badass i knew you was you know he's
coach cower he's a cbs sports team blah
blah and i came into anthony and enrique
this morning i said
did you know that bill cower's a big
deal and they both went yeah gail we
knew
we knew so anyway i love you i love love
love the book and love your story
34 years old you are head coach of the
pittsburgh steelers
and you even said that maybe you were a
little bit in over your head
when you first got the job
i was gayle you know i went back to my
hometown and i remember the night i
was offered the job i was back in kansas
city and i told my wife kay at the time
wow
i'm going back to my hometown if i don't
screw this up in three years i can go
back to my 20th high school class
reunion as a head coach my hometown team
yeah so my first goal was not to get
fired in the first three years
and ironically i did go to my 20th high
school class for union
right after we had lost the championship
game against the new england patriots
and it was a river cruise i went on a
river cruise you can't get off a river
cruise i heard about all the things that
we should have done
all my classmates tell me the things
that i i should have made mistakes i
should have made
yeah you're right but no even your dad
i'm looking at my clock
bill even your dad says god those stupid
steelers can you believe it and you said
to him what
well i said dad that was me who made
that decision he got caught up in the
moment
he was a fan and then oh yeah it's my
son he goes yeah you probably had a good
reason for it i don't think he bought it
and i thought
man my dad's right again he was right
but you said you learned a lot but you
know what
yes yes yes yeah you know i in this this
memoir
gail really to me i did it because you
know i got the hall of fame you start to
reflect on your football
life the pandemic comes you start to
reflect on your own life
it just seemed like the right time to go
back and people have this perception of
me whatever it may be
but you don't really know me and to find
the right collaborator or not being
michael hawley a guy who went to point
park college a guy who
from northeast ohio we sat down and we
put this together and it's
a series of hardships opportunities and
lessons
and that's what life is about right and
it's called
you learn from each experience it's
called personal growth bill i love the
football part but what i really loved
was her personal part
you know you were you were married to
your wife kay for close to 30 years
before she died
you clearly adored her uh you talk a
great deal about the marriage and then
after she dies you you lose your father
too in a very short period of time so
you had a huge
one-two punch then you meet another love
of your life you've got three daughters
and they're sort of questioning hey dad
how could you fall in love so quickly
and how you navigated
that relationship my stomach is growling
how you not navigated
losing the love of your life to falling
in love again and having to explain that
to your daughters it was very personal
and very candid
it was it's more personal i've ever been
there i've been i've played my
life and in kay also we were in
pittsburgh for those 15 years
we had an isolated family um it was
family was important to me i grew up
with the rooney's and
marty schottenheimer you know he was a
big influence on me and
dan rooney is a big influence on me and
if you look at their two wives pat
schottenheimer and pat rooney
you know i realized that your wife and
you and for me
all my mentors they had strong confident
nurturing wives
and i had that in kay she was my
backbone a backbone of our family
and yet you didn't want football to be
here you didn't want football to be your
life coach
no there's more to like family was more
important to me than football gal and it
still is to this day
and i've been blessed to have women in
my life that have given me that balance
that you need
yeah some men don't get one good woman
you got two so lucky you
and the hall of fame congratulations you
said you didn't realize how badly you
wanted
wanted it until they offered it to you
yeah you know when i walked away gail i
walked away for reasons of
family and i never thought i would go in
and i didn't need it to to validate
anything i did but certainly you get in
there
wow it's special it's a special group of
people you're around
very humbling and as you can see right
there sharing that with v
and my wife and my daughter that that
you know
that was a very special night for myself
and you know even one to this day i'll
never forget
well we won't forget you ever bill cower
it was really great really
really well well done it's called heart
and steel perfect title for this book
too
goes on sale this tuesday june 1st
wherever you like to buy your books